big fan of your work
thank you so much for uh doing this
interview today um
i've been talking to a lot of people in
the last year and i've been asking
everyone the same two questions to start
things off
first uh what tv series would you love
to guest star on
i'm very late coming to it but i just
started watching ozark this week
and i like it very much and
i think for any of us we all would have
loved to have been in the sopranos at
some point
but uh i guess i guess uh
i guess ozark will be the one that comes
to mind got it uh what movie
do you think you've seen the most or
what movies
oh i mean there was a period with my
younger daughter where i must have seen
the hunchback of notre dame
25 times in a couple years
i think i think it would be it would be
one of the movies i watch with my kids
what props or costumes have you
hypothetically borrowed from set because
i know you wouldn't have stolen anything
absolutely wanted to return it there's a
couple of
items of clothing that i did i did a
mini series
in there set in singapore last year
second world war series and then called
the singapore grip
and there were there were um the the
fashion of the period were very
beautiful and i really liked
the tailoring was so good um but it was
it was with the consent
and of producers
and costume uh department i must say and
then
yeah so a couple of nice jackets
from there uh equally a nice shot i did
that captain hot tin roof
in uh the west end in london a couple
years ago with
with jack o'connell and sienna miller
and it was a great production
and i i i enjoyed it so much i i uh
asked for i was given a lovely white
tuxedo jacket
so i have that from i played big daddy
and then and
big daddy was dressed in a tuxedo for
his birthday
so um there's the they're about to i
mean
there's there's lots of bits and pieces
of memorabilia around the house in los
angeles from uh
from star trek but it was all stuff that
was sent to me
you know by merchandising people that
you know thinking wanted it i guess but
i didn't particularly listen if you
don't want the star trek stuff i've
heard
it uh you know there's a lot of fans
sure sure
i'll get it out there don't worry it'll
all be recycled
exactly um you obviously started well
you started in the theater
you and and and then you made the
transition into
doing tv in the movies and i'm just
curious when did you feel like you made
it
as like a working actor in movies and tv
when did you feel like safe that oh i
can actually like
pay my mortgage or pay my rent
i well some of us feel we
we never get there but i i would say
probably mid 90s
uh i i would say you know
midway through ds9 and i was doing i was
doing quite a few
feature films as well so you know and
and
and um our exact producer
and rick berman on on on the star trek
shows was great about
cutting me loose to go and do other
films
uh you know couldn't be other episodes
so so i um i i guess
around that time i started to feel like
yes this is working
uh i was i was a big fan of hell on
wheels uh and i loved your
i loved your work with uh um anson and
common and every i mean listen i was a
big fan of the show
when you think back on the making of the
series is there anything that really
stands out
in terms of like memorable moments from
filming or just like some cool behind
the scenes trivia
and we we the hello wheels is a show
that i
i am very proud of and it was it was uh
terrific i mean it's beautifully shot it
was a terrific cast
very well written and and and it kind of
got lost in the shuffle i mean we were
on a
and it was an amc show and at the time
like mad men
and walking dead were the hot shows on
on amc but our numbers were
the only show that beat us number was uh
was was actually walking dead
and the numbers for him for all the
wheels were always very good but it
seemed to get lost in the shuffle i mean
it was never
never a contender for any of an award
season or something like that you know
it was it was never
golden globes you know emmys whatever it
uh
no i don't think i don't think you got
any nominations of any sort
um which is kind of odd because it was a
terrific show and a very popular show
you know
with audiences um
so so um yeah i mean we had some i mean
we had we had so many great uh guests
come on that show and and then some
terrific writing
and and god it's it's
it's we i mean you know we had a lot of
very i mean it was it was
sort of to me it was it was a um show
that was
um cinematic in its in its quality you
know i mean
the building the railroad building the
town the scale of it was was was
enormous
and and and it was hugely impressive
and really a wonderful place to go to
work you know
and i remember having
it there was a uh it just comes to mind
now
myself and jake webber had a scene where
we we sort of there
we we get into fisticuffs in the song
blue and then we come tumbling out the
saloon out onto the street and all that
and i'm i'm i'm not very good with
stunts and all that stuff and jake just
had out of weight
the time man taking the piss out of me
you know just like
calling you were so pathetic you were so
pathetic
you know what what are you afraid or
somebody like it's money it's
monkey there's horse [ __ ] there's you
know we gotta roll around in it
and then he capped the scene off by
hitting me with a cabbage
um which she was very pleased with uh
but there are a lot of good memories
from that show yeah i could spend a lot
of time talking about it but i have a
lot that i want to bring up but i'm just
going to say for anyone watching this
interview that has not seen hell on
wheels
it's a fantastic show i i completely
recommend it
um it's just it's really good um uh
so next thing is um when you got asked
to be on stargate atlantis to do a few
episodes
did you feel like you were cheating
cheesy
no not the least no i mean i felt i
actually felt it was like it was a good
thing to do because um i
i mean i think i've been a little unfair
to the
uh science i was never a science fiction
fan as a kid i was never
and i was never into the genre before i
did star trek and then i realized the
value of it and
how it can be used in so many ways i
mean it's you know
on star trek we covered so many
contemporary subjects
uh like in ways that you couldn't on a
contemporary show
like it was an episode about
homelessness an episode about genetic
engineering
you know stuff like that that and i just
really started to learn the value of
science fiction in a way as a genre
so i felt it was kind of like
practically my duty to go and do some
staria to support
a genre i had somewhat uh dismissed in
the past
i really enjoy far and away and um one
of the things i've heard
is that originally there was a much
longer cut of the movie
with more of tom boxing and stuff like
that um
do you remember if that movie had like
did you have a lot of deleted scenes in
that movie do you remember
quite a few yeah yeah but you expect
that on a big feature you know there
were there were quite a few
um the the the and yes there were a lot
more we shot a lot more boxing scenes
that are actually in the movie
right but that's to be that's you know
with an action scene like that you
expect that
um but but yeah it happens what happens
i mean the movie we're talking about
today pixie it
it did i got a fairly apologetic email
from
from barnaby the director and when he
was in the edit saying comments i'm
sorry we have to cut
you know there's two or three scenes
here about the
family and the character i play that we
just because we just ha
it just take it's taking too long to get
into the story
of the film it's too much exposition too
much establishment of characters
so and i understand that completely you
know that's that's that's
that happens um and uh
so yeah it was further away it was i
mean
i had no idea what the the the
the number or or the timings would be
but
it was yeah quite a bit deleted uh i'm
gonna get to pixie i promise we're
getting there
um but uh for for eagle eye viewers they
will remember you
as a pilot in die hard too
every time i watch die r2 i'm always
like and there he is um
so what was that like a day shoot for
you was that like a half
what was that listen that turned into it
that that was that was an extraordinary
uh
one we i was put yeah we were booked
myself had a buddy of mine james
lancaster who plays the co-pilot
and were booked for a day and
uh we were so we were on a daily rate
but then they they kept they pushed and
pushed me
they were having trouble finding snow in
an airport they were moving around
and they were supposed to shoot in
denver i think and there was no snow
there so they went somewhere else
and they'd come back to los angeles
because we shot that in the studio
obviously
um and then they come back and
say we're going to shoot that you know
thursday
so okay so we and myself and james ended
up on this
uh like i mean we must have been on it
for six weeks
are you serious yeah yeah because they
went came back when we
just kept going they could never get
around to that scene
but they kept booking us we weren't
delight we were very happy we we uh
it was it was a you know an unexpected
and
fairly lucrative game i was going to say
that's amazing
one day's work for six weeks yeah yeah
yeah uh you had a small uh you were you
got to be part of dick tracy and work
with warren beatty
was that like can you talk a little bit
about being a part of that one
well i'm very little to do it i think
i've actually i don't think i'm actually
in the final cut at all
uh i i i i made the stab and
uh last of the mohicans i think there's
another one where i i think i'm on the
credits but they actually cut the scene
as good scenes maybe i should get a
complex about this i don't think i'm in
dick tracy at all
uh and and i you know very little to do
a warranty
and i i remember doing an evening
looping with them in
on the sound stage and and uh
having a couple of chats about this that
you're a very pleasant man but
you know i can't say i really got to
know him or got to really work with him
well this explains why i didn't see you
but i did i'm asking about this base
from imdb
and i'm like i've never seen him in the
movie but like he has to be in it it's
listed
but let's move on i'm not sure if you
like guinness or not but i've been lucky
enough to go to dublin
and i would like to know your opinion on
why uh guinness tastes so much better in
dublin
um i think there's something to do with
the water and it's also something i i
just don't think it travels well
uh the other reasons people in ireland
generally are
borrowers in ireland are very conscious
of you know there's very high standards
set
for guinness and there's no one more no
more critical
and than the guinness drinker about the
quality of the guinness
including myself um and uh
so they have to they have to serve a
very good point
and in order to do that they're aware
they have to be cleaning the pipes the
tubes
that come from the barrel to the tap is
hugely important
and they have to be kept clean and they
have to be you know
been said like weekly and i know i don't
think
anybody overseas appreciates that so
they don't they don't
it's partly due to the bars the way they
keep together
for people that are watching this who
eventually can go to dublin and visit
my god you need to drink guinness in a
bar there it tastes amazing it does it
does
it's beautiful there jumping into pixie
which is i know the reason we get to
talk to them
um what was it uh what was it about the
script that you really responded to
what was it that said i want to do this
oh it was such a joy to read it was it
was um
you know the script arrived at pixie
okay it was a complete page turner it
was
um it had me laughing out loud
frequently
um i'm just an absolute pleasure
absolute joy to read i i was
you know just delighted with it and then
i went because
as i normally do go back and look at the
character that you you know you're being
asked
to play yeah and and again it was like
oh man this guy is great you know
a gangster who's just sort of like just
sick of it all he's just had enough to
hear he only wants to do is listen to
opera and cook nice food
this is a great character you know
everything about him
such a guy yeah i i there was a little
bit of a
sopranos-esque thing to your character
because it shows
there's a lot with your family and a lot
that's just not you running around
killing people
it's you know it's portraying you in a
three-dimensional light
yeah i agree absolutely and and i i was
a bit concerned i i think
you know they they got it right in the
end you know barnaby is
a consummate director he is uh
as i said earlier he he he had sent me
that email about
um having to having to cut some couple
of seeds to get into the
actual action story quicker and i was a
bit concerned about about that balance
being lost between the
this guy who's sort of a family guy and
quite cultivated
in many ways quite civilized likes his
opera likes his wines likes his
you know his cuisine and and and the guy
who goes up and beats the [ __ ] out of
people you know
uh but i think in the end they got all
because
from audience reactions i think they
seem to get that they get that
the dual aspects of this guy you know
there are still scenes of you
in the movie um cooking and family stuff
and uh it's amazing how even like one
scene of that can
say so much you know yes indeed
absolutely yeah yeah yeah one of the
things that i found surprising about the
movie and maybe you could talk about it
is
right from the beginning it is fast
moving and violent
it is like it just jumps in it does not
it does not pull a punch it
hits you right over the face right at
the beginning
well i would absolutely agree and i
think that's what barney b was uh
bernie was was was was looking for that
one that's exactly what he wanted and
that's why those
scenes were deleted i think it's it's uh
it it's a wonderfully paced
and you know beautifully shot john de
boerman did the the photography it's
beautifully shot
um and i'm brilliantly active i think i
mean it's just a great cast and
everywhere you look there's these great
characters
great faces and yeah you know wonderful
performances chris wally is a wonderful
a wonderful actor and i've worked with
since as well
uh has that you know it's just not a
huge part but he's
he's the drug dealer at the beginning of
it all who works
who works as a baggage handler at the
airport and of course goes through
everyone's bags and
you know likes likes to use the uh
lemare you know the 400
a jar cream and he's he's using it on
his face
just just detail like that is just so so
beautiful
yeah the one thing also about the film
is that every time
olivia and the other characters are
driving all it did was make me be like i
gotta go back to dublin
and ireland
it is it is it's beautiful beautiful
scenery yeah um
as i say beautifully sharp as well you
know
oh no completely the i don't want to do
spoilers at all but there's
in the third act you get to uh do some
stuff with alec baldwin
um i'm assuming you're just as much of a
fan as i am
oh absolutely yeah yeah yeah we knew
each other vegan way back back in the
80s in the theater in new york you know
we never worked together but
there were we crossed paths in a few
bars a few times and uh
and it's it's uh it was wonderful to
to to spend spending a few days working
on this we had
we had so much fun it was great it was
great because you know the nature of the
nature of the of the work as well you
know
the gangster priest and the and and the
history we had to you know
as characters the history of the
characters together it was just it was
just a joy
i wanted to switch into a little bit of
star trek um if you don't mind and the
thing that
is amazing is that you were only you're
only behind michael dorn
in terms of i believe you have 225
appearances
um in star trek which is only behind
michael doran what does that mean to you
to be um in so much of the
of two series um
i'm not sure i'm getting old enough what
does it mean to me
um i yeah you know i i i never
consider that that um actually because
you know
i was never a regular on on the next
generation and there's only every guest
and so i i i kind of considered you know
deep space nine my star trek years if
you like you know from
from 92 to 99 um
which is seven years which is what
pretty much all the series around for
about seven years you know
um so i i don't um i don't think of
himself as being uh
uh uh um
you know as sending any records or
anything like that it seemed like either
kind of normal
span so that's interesting surprising
interesting
um i absolutely love deep space nine i
think that the show even when it was
airing i loved it
and um i'm just curious for you what is
it like
being part of a series that people still
want to talk about after
over 20 years later
it's great i mean i think it's a tribute
to the writing it's a tribute to the the
performances
you know and the production values that
it still holds up
and you know it's it's it's it's
a real a real that i i think
you know recognition of how good a show
it was
i guess what i'm curious about as an
actor when you were making like ds9 and
you
you went over to that series were you
nervous every year that you might get
cancelled or was it one of these things
where you felt like
the syndication deals were very strong
and you'd be
you know you were safe no i don't think
we ever had any concerns like that um
you know there was a little there was
quite a bit of resistance to be at the
beginning to deep spacetime because it
wasn't on a ship
it wasn't a you know it was on station
uh and a lot of people said oh so it's
very dark and it's very this
and you know we weren't worried about
that because
there had been resistance to the next
generation when it first came on as well
the first two or three
i think next generation was probably
closer to being cancelled
early in its life like in the second
third season than perhaps we were
because i think parliament had realized
by the time we came along
that these shows take a while to play in
for for
the star trek audience to get used to
them as it were
i'm curious if you can share um for for
the average person
um can what was it actually like behind
the scenes making next generation and
deep space nine
and were the shows similar for you i
know that you were a regular on ds9
but i'm just curious what it was like
behind the scenes in terms of
you know making the series if you if
there was a difference between these two
series
no they felt very similar actually um i
mean we had a lot of the same crew
uh was interchangeable like marvin rush
the dp on there
on next generation came over to shoot
ds9
and the camera crew uh with the same
um i i would say i would say they were
very similar
um yeah in
in in that aspect of it you know the
actual shooting of it
a lot of your fellow cast mates um would
direct an episode or two and i know that
you never directed one was it something
that you actually wanted to pursue
or was it something that you were
content to just be acting on
on the series i i i do not understand
why every actor wants to be a director
um it baffles me i i
am i think there's enough good directors
out there
who don't work enough and i think
you know i believe in i mean what i do
best is act
um and really if i if i did want to
direct i would want to direct a feature
film not an episode of television
because
it's really a producer writer's medium
episodic television you know it's not a
director's medium
you can't really stamp your own you know
identity on an episode of a show you
have to it's it's a format
and you deliver that format and so i i
know i know i mean
i produce i've produced a film here in
spain
with a local director and i'm in the
process of trying to set up another film
to shoot here later in the year
um and i i think i can i can contribute
in that way
but as a director why
i mean there's so many great directors
out there
and that and as i say a lot of them
don't work enough
the other thing about um star trek is
that you guys obviously had a shooting
schedule
you had to hit certain pages a day it's
very hard to
throw a interesting camera angle in or
spend a lot of time on a oner when you
need to film three four pages a day or
whatever that number
absolutely and and and the same is true
in in
in the film world more and more you know
you have to hit a certain number of
pages a day i mean you know i i
i recently did a a feed film
that we shot in 14 days it's very short
i got there i couldn't believe that was
the schedule
it's it's i would not no i would not
like to be a director out there trying
to shoot a feature filled in 14 days
did you ever ask the writers on ds9 why
they constantly tortured you again and
again
that's probably the question i'm asked
most about this garage right yeah and
no no i think um i think i i i almost
assumed it was it was
a tribute to my acting ability i'm
joking
um i um
no i i mean i think it was just that he
was kind of like
the the uh the frontline guy as it were
you know what i mean he was he kind of
kind of got stuck in
these situations more than he should
have perhaps
um yeah no i mean
i i i i have to say when we were doing
it i never really felt that i never
really felt
now should have been tortured again and
you know just kind of next episode you
know
how often are you challenged to a game
of darts
never really yeah liver
the thing that they they think of like
you know as a kind of sid being british
me being irish
and what they do what do they do in pubs
in britain uh
they do it in britain they don't they
don't do it in pubs in ireland
you wouldn't find a dartboard in an
irish pub you find them in an english
book
um but that's that's that's like where
that came from
you know i'm sure you're aware of star
trek picard going on and and
patrick stewart's back doing it and um
there's a lot of interest on uh with
star trek
on paramount plus which is now it's
called the streaming service
is revisiting o'brien in some way shape
or form
something that you're interested in or
is it something that it's from your past
i'm happy
it happened and i think
i've always felt like seven years days
it was long enough you know
um i i yeah
yeah i i don't i don't know i mean as i
get older you know you kind of get a bit
nostalgic about
about um some of the stuff you've done
in the past and it might it might be
nice to go back and
you know uh have a look at it again but
i i don't i mean i don't believe it very
often i mean
generally speaking over the years i've
been i would have been reluctant
to to go back to what brothers have to
say
but you know you've never seen it ever i
don't know if you
are aware of this but um there's a an
animated star trek series called lower
decks
and in a recent episode they talked
about o'brien
and how he's the most important
starfleet character of all time
wow finally finally they got it right
huh
one of the things that a lot of people
don't realize is that when you were
making star trek ds9
you were doing 26 episodes a season
which is a huge number of television
and i'm curious what it was like as an
actor um
because you know for you you had a big
cast
so you didn't have to be on set 24 7 all
the time
but what was it like making a show that
was 26 episodes a year
yeah it was a tough schedule it was it
was um and the ones i really you know
at the time felt really you know fell
for where
were the crew i mean the crew were there
you know you're
everybody from camera crew to you know
lighting sound
production you know they were there
there all day every day
and there were days we did 16 hour days
and that you know that show it wasn't
unusual
uh five days a week nine months of the
year
um it's a it was a very very tough
schedule
and as you said being an ensemble cast
like we were
we got blind like to be shows where you
know i have three or four shows where
i'm heavy when i've got a lot to do
and then three or four shows where i'm
like i just come in two three days maybe
for the episode
and that's how i was able also to get
out to do other things was that you know
rick bermuder exec producer was very
helpful in this way he would put
maybe two two or three episodes together
where i'm really light
you know uh so i could go
for something for a couple of weeks come
back and do a day on one episode
another episode and go again and so i'd
still be in the episode but very little
you know
did you i know you've probably been
asked this before but did you have any
sort of favorite story lines
that you got to be a part of or favorite
story lines that weren't even your
character
and they just meant a lot to you there
was an episode of dsl we did about
homelessness
in in in los angeles trying to travel
involved back to i think like 2040
and um it was it was a powerful episode
i remember and
where where the homelessness had all
been corralled together in an area of
los angeles
and the rest of society referred to them
as the gibbs
and it was really really powerful
and and it it demonstrated to me
um as i may have said earlier and how
how
science fiction can address contemporary
social issues in a way that a lot of
contemporary shows can't
it was i thought it was quite brilliant
that show i was a big fan of your
relationship with bashir on
you know with alexander uh and i thought
you guys had great chemistry and you
were always having
you know it was a very fun relationship
to watch on screen
what was it like working with him and
just you know
uh collaborating with him on so many
scenes
it was i should say it was it was a
pleasure in it man
sid and i got on really well we didn't
you know we didn't have to talk about
a lot we didn't have to analyze what we
were doing just kind of
it was like you know jamming together
that's all
just just you know we just did it do you
remember when you were making the series
what was really difficult to pull off
um was something maybe that was in the
script that you're like oh this is going
to be a real pain
whether it be an action beat or whether
it just be whatever
you know behind the scenes well i mean
the constant throwing i think you know
our science was uh was what we described
as technobabble
um you know you'd always check the
script as soon as you got it do it
that didn't come easily you had to do it
by road you know what i mean you really
had to
to uh learn that stuff like
you did your times tables at school you
know um
so you know and you'll always check the
script uh before you started shooting as
soon as you got the script you jumped
check it out for technobabble you don't
see
because because you know the rest the
rest of the dialogue is dialogue and you
rehearse
it comes very easily but that
that stuff you had to you had to really
nail i actually had
i i didn't even think about that but
that makes complete sense
so were you was one of the was was
making that series
where every day you were getting
different color pages
or was it pretty much when you got the
script it was closer to locked
no no we'd go through we'd go through
several rain colors
buff green white
blue pink uh you know uh
and sometimes go through them a second
time yeah that was multicolored
did you i'm not sure if you actually are
you someone that can watch yourself on
screen
did you actually watch star trek as it
aired have you seen the episodes
no you so you haven't did you so you
never saw the finale of next generation
or the finale of deep space nine
i didn't actually know and i keep
meaning to
oh well i'm just going to say that the
finale on the next generation is
what we call kind of awesome um it's
it's it's quite good i recommend it
right right i'm just throwing that up
check it out
yeah um so my last thing for you is
you're in spain right now what
and i'm just curious what drew you to
living there i i'm always curious when
someone wants to live in a place
that is um i'm always curious how people
land where they're gonna be yeah um
my wife she's french but she had lived
and worked in madrid a lot
uh in the 90s and then she and she spent
summers here in mallorca
and she was very fun and i was
i was planning in the you know early
around the turn of the century to i was
looking i was thinking of moving to uh
to not moving but wanting to spend more
time in europe and
looking at spain south of france and
italy and that and
she persuaded me to come and look at new
yorker and we did and
we love it it's a beautiful island it
really is it's it's
uh it's it's you know mediterranean it's
south coast of the barcelona south
barcelona and
east of valencia and then there's the
three islands
ubita new yorker menorca um
and and majorca is the biggest stuff and
it's it's
it's a spectacularly beautiful island we
love it here
i was gonna say you can just be honest
and say you wanted to be close to ibiza
i get it
i get it you know yeah
right um my last thing for you you've
done a lot of theater work and
what i'm fascinated by are the different
audiences that exist around the world
for theater um and i'm just curious and
i've spoken to a lot of actors that have
done theater
do you notice um different energy
in different places when you're
performing for example the west end or
wherever it may be
have you do you feel that on stage
yes i think you do and
[Music]
it also depends on the material you know
and it's actually it's
just the last show i did that play
that you could in other words compare
like that was
um move the misbegotten that was seven
with kevin spacey at the old vic in
london
and then we we we moved it to broadway
um and that that was interesting in that
there were different responses i think i
think broadly our
audiences were a bit tighter a bit more
a bit less
um willing to roll with
which is surprising considering you know
you would think it would be the british
audience that would be
a bit more con you know restrained or
whatever and
but then you know we did i did um
iceman cometh from broadway a couple of
years ago with denzel
washington and uh and that was
a very different uh sort of american
audience to me it was it was a
completely giving
freewheeling wonderful wonderful uh
wonderful and responsive audience and
then
another show i did captain roof in in
in london with jack o'connell and sienna
miller and we
we um we noticed a difference in
audiences
there actually the matinee audience was
always much more
much tighter and harder to deal with
that may be a question of age older
people coming in
you know from updates than the evening
audiences
i think the evening has probably had
more drinks
maybe as well yeah did you find when
you're doing something with denzel that
every person you know is calling you for
tickets
oh yeah absolutely yeah i
can't i can't imagine the ticket
requests on something yeah yeah
yeah no but that's true anytime you do a
show on broadway you got that
oh yeah i wouldn't know what that's
about people ask for them
i could go on and on but um i it's late
where you are and i
i i'm just gonna say thank you um uh
sincerely i'm a really big fan of your
work
and um your time on star trek uh meant a
lot to me
and uh also the dad who is recording
this um
well you know i wish you nothing but the
best
thank you so much steve i really
appreciate it i appreciate you getting
up early and doing this and
i hope we talk again soon and bump into
each other in toronto or
some berlin or sundance or venice or
somewhere